acheter je t'ai abandonné remplacer nous
sommes dans une ère où les objets ont
une durée de vie très faible et
finissent très rapidement à la poubelle
jean-paul à trouver une solution à cette
logique du tout jeter les ateliers
réparé bricole passionnés de travaux
manuels depuis tout petit il en a fait
son activité professionnelle et souhaite
transmettre sa passion le temps d'une
journée on le retrouve à la manivelle
la recyclerie du mesnil-saint-denis pour
un atelier réparation d'appareils
électroménagers et affûtage pour les
particuliers alors réparé bricole on
veut par des bricoles qui sont
insignifiants mais qui ont de la valeur
si on peut prendre exemple le cas d'un
sécateur qui a été réfuté qu'il veut
briller et couple comme comme une paire
de ciseaux et je vais avec un jeu
stabile reproduire c'est pour de
manuellement et là
cet outil est prêt pour jardiner de haut
des bonnes conditions
de ça notre registre donc affaire à
repasser et qui avait ses soucis de
chauffe et il suffisait de nettoyer le
contact du thermostat
il est moche air de racheter l'objet
neuf que de le réparer donc la démarche
c'est plus défi écologique et une prise
de conscience qu'on peut réparer certain
nombre d'objets je dirais solesmes et
oui tout nouvel objet fabriqué utilisent
de l'énergie pour les machines qui vont
l'assemblée et les transports qui vont
la cheminée mais ils consomment aussi
des ressources naturelles pour ces
matériaux ressources planétaires qui ne
sont pas infinies donc réparer plutôt
que jeter c'est une démarche pour moins
gaspiller pour ça venez faire un tour à
la manivelle du mesnil-saint-denis
nouvelles boutiques ouvertes il ya
quelques mois vous pourrez peut-être
fait dénicher la perle rare que vous
cherchez